Good morning.
Yeah.
I want to do what I did it last time
around the test just to walk very quickly
through the test questions
and a sort of test myself.
How would I respond to them? Uh, uh,
there's a lot for today to cover,
so I'm Ivo rush.
Um, uh, oh,
let me just one more time emphasize,
uh,
uh, you have plenty of
time to do that, right?
I have a discussion section at seven,
so I don't want to reach the, something
is going on their own with the Internet.
So I will post this before
my discussion section, uh,
before seven. Exactly. Then I don't know,
I mean I have these anxieties hops was
talking about and therefore I don't want,
I, I prefer to be five minutes early
rather than being an hour late. Right.
So some,
sometimes before seven UVF find it.
Then you have to send you around
set around nine o'clock. Uh, if,
uh, uh, you know,
some of you communicated that you need
another time because you are a already
engagements, uh, um, uh, it is all of us,
you have to vary the south beach. You're
a discussion section leader, right?
Um, and your discussion section leader
of yours take care of you or your needs.
Um, uh, and we be brief, right?
Sort of the two questions should
be about more like four to six,
um, a double space that babies
that had did and much longer,
I mean, maybe like Sept
Eight, so we are not,
you will not be penalized if you are
longer, but the point is not to be long,
but to, to be, to be crispy. And again,
the point is, you know, you
know, you try to show, uh,
the different views of the auteurs
and then comment on it further,
which is more sense of law,
right?
And I toured that you're the cure
that have had paper goes this way.
You spend a turd presenting run water
after about an opponent of that altar,
and then, uh, your reflections
on it, right? That's about it.
So let me then rush through. This
is not an easy question, right?
Marx theory are fairly young nation
Nicha or fried theory or from a
civilization.
I mean,
that is a common feature right?
Between the three orchard. Uh, um,
uh, the city or the ask to create a
controversy between the two. Right?
You can be too. Um, usually, um,
the common featured is that they are all
concerned about modernity and people's
sense of being lost and being result
control in modernity and the problem of
modernity that we are too much control
and the control is increasingly inside us
that, uh, then outside
and coercive. Right?
I think that's the common
feeling. Uh, uh, I think I made,
uh, this point, uh, uh,
in, in the lecture, um,
if you read a 20th century literature,
particularly first half,
you find these feeling
expressed by a lot of novelists.
You read Franz Kafka, right? Uh, uh, you,
you read the Albert Kami,
that's where you get that
same feeling expressed, uh,
to what Mark Snitcher and
fried artists bonding too.
But there are big differences,
right? Uh, Mark's,
uh,
tries to move away from Hagar and wants
to come down to earth and offer a theory
of value our nation, which
is rooted in the economy, in,
into the production process.
And Marx has a view of what emancipate
that society VOB and he even has a
historic agent will get us
there. Uh, to emancipation,
the proletariat, uh, now nutri
is about it different. I,
the genealogical matter does not
really offer you the right solution,
right?
The genealogical method a orally
shores you about his unique,
uh,
in modernity and modern morality
in the Judeo Christian morality,
but you think is so attractive
and so mobile and he shows, right?
Um,
how,
right in the workshop
that ideas are produced,
it's actually torture and the
pressure and what operates right.
So that is no a good society and
no agent who will get you there,
right? You have to do
it by yourself. Now fry,
there's all sorts is civilization,
um,
as a coming from repression of sexual
drives and I saw a years and a critique of
civilization, right? Um,
but at the same time,
pride has these dual attitude
about civilization, right?
A civilization is coming from repression,
but it is still sublimation and the
most beautiful things in human society.
The Art and science are
coming from the sublimation.
And he is also reflecting,
he's writing in 1932 the rise of
Nazism and NT Wright civilization.
And he does not want to support
that. Right? So in a way you,
no one can say that. What he does
not have, he does not offer you, um,
uh, uh, division of, with
society to some extent.
He is with Nicha.
He said you have to emancipate yourself.
You have to figure it out for
yourself, but your problem is, uh, uh,
and he does certainly does not fit
the head of our historic agent.
Like mark says. Anyway, this is the bay,
Hawaii would be dealing with
this and I've got Vietnam there.
You have what my opinion is.
I want to hear your opinion about them.
Okay. The second question, uh,
that's not, uh, not easy either.
Practical theory of to send
nature genealogical method there,
there is again,
a common Emela LMN
between marks and Nicha.
Neither of them believes Ian.
Objective, abstract throughs,
right? Um, uh,
mark says there is no
objective abstract tools. Uh,
truth is like practical question throughs
is being achieved by the end by human
practices, right? Uh,
and Nichelle, of course,
does not believing in
objective truths, right? Uh,
he's trying to find truth,
but truth is being
accomplished by comparing,
you know,
different notions of mortality and to
show that in comparison with each other,
most heavies, upsides and
downsides, right? So that is, uh,
um, uh, uh, uh, he by the very nature,
don't misunderstand him. He is
not a knee healist. He doesn't,
he does not see everything
goes Nikki elitism or is, is,
is a very negative term for nature.
So he does not want to say that
is no two said, oh, he said,
truth is just relative and you can
arrive at critical understanding of your
situation by comparing your
situation with, with an order bomb.
That is of course, a very
fundamental different, again,
between a marks.
I'm a niche here because what
is this practical truths?
These are human activities.
And Mark's basically arrives at
this human activities, uh, uh,
thrill changing the physical words through
the system of production. And again,
he has the agent who is a,
uh,
this is the revolution and the
practices of the product diarrhea,
which really get you to the truth. That
is nothing like that in nature, right?
Nature does not have a history.
Got Adrian and does not have the society,
uh,
where after or, uh, uh,
or uveal yet to through society.
Well, this is actually a very
simple question. Can't, you know,
many of you did not like
it. So I'm, you know,
I'm thinking very hard that had to put it
on. It's a bit narrow, but very simple.
Um,
a German ideology under good.
Andre's a very simple,
there are two unique features
in the German ideology.
One is when he def,
he does develop the notion
of mode of production for
the first time in this book,
45, uh, 1845,
but he does identify the
nature of, uh, uh, uh, uh,
mode of production,
primarily by division of Labor.
And this doesn't serve him very valid
because the division of labor does not
capture the conflictuous
relationships between classes,
which eventually will have
to lead to revolution.
So he abandoned since it does not finish
the book because only at the very end
of the book does he realize that uh,
uh,
the two component of a mode of production
as a forces of production technology
and the relations of production and
the relations of production, uh,
for most of the German
ideology is division of Labor.
And then he realized his, no, no,
no, it is not division of labor,
but a [inaudible] relations,
the relationship between those who
have property and those who do not have
property.
Um,
and he also has a very deterministic
view of history in the German ideology.
All societies have to go through
the same modes of production.
Um, dry bullyism slave mode of
production, a few dollars, man capitalism,
uh, in the ground he said
that are two big innovations.
Now the center is property relations.
Uh,
he studied the beak of history.
If capita is van,
the producer is separated from the
means of production completely.
Um, and he breaks from the, uh,
a deterministic view of
history. Right now he has, he,
these Marty linner development of history.
Not every society has to come
through slavery. And feudalism,
the Asiatic societies in a glares,
I communal society can move
directly into capitalism. Okay.
So that's basically a
very simple question.
I probably did a very bad job in the
lecture that this did not become clear.
A set form.
Mark's is a historical materialist
and compare him with Frye.
Now, uh, I actually am
inspired here by, uh,
Juergen Habermas and you're going,
Habermas says there are marks in the
thesis on fire Buck. Got It. Right.
Then he said that the real point of
departure is sensors, human activity.
Uh,
at time then harbor moss was writing this.
She was still a material
is then he had his culture.
Turnon is probably not a material
is standing wrong. He said,
materialism is,
if you point of departure is what
you can get through your senses,
not through your ideas. But he
said, Mark's made a mistake. Uh,
namely that he reduced census
human activities to the economy,
um, and to production. And there are,
he said a fried is more
interesting because he has
a different kind of sensors,
human activity and this is census,
human activities between people,
right?
Sexual relationships. In fact, harbor
must makes it more complicated. You know,
it's,
I don't want to get into harbor mass,
but he's interpretation of Fridays
at fried is also starts from sensors.
Human activity to understand
what is in people's mind.
But it is not economic reductionism.
If anything it is sexual.
Uh, uh, reduction is man,
it is a ban erotic explanation of history,
but in some ways, you know,
they all stars for sensors,
human activities in explaining
what can it be in people's mind.
What is our ideas though?
The starting point is material
sensors experience, right?
And the product ad ideas that this is in
the sense the are most material is but
in different ways.
Is that I,
I suppose it should be pretty clear now.
All right.
Okay. Uh, classes, well,
you can have different views on this
and especially whether in Marx theory of
classes are still applicable.
You know,
Marcy find classes in terms
of property relationship.
He had two classes, uh, in
the communist manifesto.
The bourgeois has the younger
proletariat. Uh, the question is,
does it still matter and
you have to reflect on this.
Do you think property relations still
is a major antagonistic divided in
American society or not?
Andy longer. And of course,
Marx believed in the communist manifesto.
Yes, that is the lower middle class.
But it will be that of a middle class of
you'll become either bourgeois artwork,
it'd become a proletarian.
And of course in the United States,
the Vista received wisdom is that Vro
or middle class are the or middle class.
Uh, I would love to hear your view about
this. Right? But that's the big question.
Clearly marks the it wrong. That's
undoubtedly, I think everybody agree.
I think Karl Marx, if he wouldn't be
alive, he would say, ah, I screwed it.
I made a mistake. Of course, that
is a big middle class. Right? Um,
so I mean, uh, you don't have,
you don't have to really, uh,
hate marks. You know that
there is a middle class. He
believes he made a mistake.
Right. Uh, anyway, but you
can, you can ask the question,
who is the middle class are indeed
V or middle class? Is there,
is this sensible to talk about
the big bourgeoisie that I know,
big Buzz Razia any longer.
This is people's capitalism.
Bolivian as these other questions. I
would like you to deal with it. Okay.
Labor theory of value and that I'm Smith.
I thought this is a very easy
question, right? Uh, Adam Smith Sad,
uh, that you know, or uh, well
value is created by labor,
but then he said when it comes
to distributing, yeah, uh, uh,
Val's so or income,
it has to go to labor capital and uh,
land. Uh, Mark's on the other hand
set, val, this is contradiction.
If all labor goes to a four,
value is created by labor,
but it should go to labor and
therefore it is taken away for labor.
Should be understood as exploitation.
Is this an advance or is this a
misunderstanding? And you can say, well,
this is a misunderstanding
because a Adam Smith's was right.
He said, Oh, labor is, or,
or value is created by labor in societies
where capital is not accumulated and
the land is not privately owned. And
therefore this is a consistent argument.
Or you can say,
well,
Mark's actually got a very important
point because there is indeed exploitation
there. Alex brought to relationships
and he does drive history.
I mean how you take your position,
this is up to you.
You have to argue consistently that
and the argument of consistent they've,
you'll be revived at seven.
Well this is again,
a lot of people said don't do it because
we have not talked about domination.
I probably alleviate because I've,
you're talking the, uh, in the next, uh,
uh,
how much I have got 40 minutes about this,
um,
uh,
domination and of production and world
domination is where Protestant ethic
cross, he is an ideal is some people
think that this is a too narrow question.
Then I think you kind of, um, we
can, um, uh, ask the question,
is this really an Nadia is few,
some people said,
but vapor is saying that it is,
uh,
Calvin is in which created a capitalism.
Is this his view?
What is exactly his view? Uh, um, is, uh,
he's uh, is very critical of marks. Um,
uh, is, uh, uh, he believes that,
you know, Mark's has a simplistic,
a materialist explanation.
It is consciousness which letter it is
existence which determines countries and
has that are then the other way around.
Um,
is a vapor saying the opposite.
It is a consciousness bitch debtor
and man's existence or capitalism.
And uh, that's, that's what, uh, the
Patterson that is trying to do. Uh,
and of course he has this interesting
notion of elective affinity questions
about that that is really a
causal relationship between
ideas and the economy.
And you can labor on this, uh, what
he might mean and what you think.
This is a cop out, right?
That he actually, uh,
um,
uh,
his marks more of a contemporary
social theorist because he has a causal
explanation.
He tries to give scores,
I'll explanation and that's what you
are taught in political science or
economics, but we are social science
comes up with causal explanations, right.
And Mike VBA shy survey and mark
stash to do causal analysis.
Okay.
Uh,
did I miss [inaudible]?
Well,
this is very much a very,
very similar to the
previous question here.
Only I ask you to compare
the two is mark three yearly,
a simple minded economic determinist,
the the term minister.
It is a existence which debtor and
mass consciousness, what is, he has a,
has a more complicated view.
Is that a contradiction in Mark's
right or the philosophy of Praxis,
that yard making history. He also
makes that claim. How does it fit?
That's just simply contradict himself
or is this a consistent ideology and you
know, Labor is, he and I are the of the
store. He is not really an idea. This,
what does he mean by these elective
affinity? And then the final,
the final question.
I think people seem to be liking
this and now the easy by the vape,
Mark's clearly has a notion of
um, uh, uh, uh, human nature,
right? Mark's beliefs is a real soya
and an even more radical than Russo.
Ian Theory of human nature,
especially in his theory, uh, of, uh,
alienation, right? We are good.
And the problem comes as society,
uh,
makes us alienated.
But I think he goes a
little beyond the, uh, uh,
Rousseau because he thinks
that in the state of nature,
we are actually social being
social is in our nature,
a full ride. Rousseau
did not think so. Um, uh,
the mobile savage has to be
socialized into CVS society.
Mice believes that this whole idea
of state of nature is an abstraction.
We are all born in society
and by nature we are social.
All of the capital isn't,
which makes us competitive.
Competitive Bourgeois
individuals makes us our short,
he saw Straw and egoistic now does
vapor has a theory of human nature.
It's a more difficult question to pose.
I think if,
if I would argue, I would say
they [inaudible] last have one.
It is closer to hops because he
does believe that people are the,
the history of human can is a
struggle for power. That yeah.
Unending struggle for power.
And that's,
that's why he explained human history
with power struggles. That's about it.
That's the way how I would do that
much shell try to deal with this.
I hope this was somewhat helpful.
Uh, and, uh,
makes you relaxed, right? That this
will not be a difficult test. Uh,
uh, it will be actually a lot
of fun to deal with this, uh,
intriguing, interesting issues. Okay.
Uh, and believe me, id or
he wants you to have fun. I,
uh, uh, uh,
I think these are interesting
questions. Uh, okay,
now we come to labor theory of
domination and that's almost impossible,
but I'm trying to do now,
but we'll try to rush you through.
Um, and first of all, if you have
to understand VBA theory of action,
uh, uh, which, uh, uh, has
some similarities to Hoppes,
what Hoppes, Yardi or voluntaristic
action, uh, but then, uh,
we also have to deal with Weber's
a notion of rationality. Uh,
and then, uh, his distinction
between power and domination. Uh,
he's sturdy of legitimacy. This is
very, very important. Uh, it's, um,
uh, one of the most
fundamental, uh, concept, uh,
in particularly in political theory but
also in economics and the in sociology.
Um,
and finally his Stipe's off authority
Viveo deal at great lengths with different
types of authority.
I just give you a sense of what
this is in the next 25 minutes.
Okay.
The four types of economic action,
he makes a distinction that
that question is how can,
how are the orienting with
each other about motivates us,
van Vr interacting with other people.
He said where we can act
instrumental, the rational, the end.
I'd be like spelling it to you,
what he means. And then he said,
we can or you also act very
rash and Molly and again,
we all come explain what this means.
Uh,
in our interaction we can,
uh,
led by our emotions.
And he said,
this is well, this is rational. He said,
this is not on the rational thing.
It,
it is not necessarily on rational that
we act out of our emotions and ivy will
tell you then he thinks
this is becoming irrational,
acting out of emotion or in our,
we can be led by tradition.
Now to understand this,
that you know,
that we actually interact with each
other in very different ways over time.
You know,
be the same person.
We can act occasionally instrumentality
or occasionally we can act them a
factually right or occasionally we act
over somebody because we have a great
deal of emotion or feeling love or
the hate and occasionally they can act
instrumental, right? The use somebody
in order to achieve somebody.
Can I borrow $20 from you?
Right? Then the Act instrumental,
uh, but we also can act
out of a heat or, or love,
right. Um, in a discussion section,
I really hate the guts of somebody
with all of us speaking right in the
discussion section and then I just
will contradict because, you know,
I just,
it is my antagonism or I just sympathize
with somebody and therefore I also tend
to disagree,
basically driven by my emotion.
And now I even not talking about
love of which combines people. Uh,
more.
Now what is behind this is
Weber's fundamental methodology.
He calls his approach to society.
Uh,
interpretative sociology.
The term interpretative sociology
is translated from German.
The German term is Featherston.
Verstehen means understanding occasionally
they also translated into English.
That fourth vapor does is understand
Weber's strong commitment.
Is that social analyst be eaten?
Economist be a political scientist.
The sociologists be a historian,
a be an anthropologist is not two
plus value judgements on other,
but to try to understand what drives other
people don't assume that other people
because the egg differently than
you would have in that situation,
that they are done evil or irrational.
Right?
This is particularly a
debate with economists.
Economists tend to have very strong
conception that that is one economical,
irrational behavior they ever said.
No,
I mean that are the values stype of this,
how we can act and my job is not to
say now you've already irrational.
My job is to try to put myself into your
position and to understand why you did
and why you did do they,
how you did it.
This is interpretative sociology,
right?
This is understanding fash there,
right? That I am more sure.
Naughty tried to put myself into your
situation and rather than saying,
this is what I will do,
Ivs,
obviously if I were you
right in your situation,
would I do the same thing? Why? Why
do you do that the way how you do,
do assuming that you are
not acting irrationally,
but try to understand by
you, activate you act. Okay.
Now let's talk about
instrumental irrational acture.
This comes through the closest,
but, uh, most economists,
especially now classical economists
regard as rational economic action.
He said instantly, mentally,
uh, rational actually cross it.
Sabec Roseo naughty date. Um, uh, uh, uh,
is when the ends and the means,
uh,
or rationally taken into
account and they did right?
This is kind of utility maximization,
right?
When you utilitarians defined
this as the rational way to act,
right,
that you have,
you are striving for happiness and
you tried to achieve this happiness.
And in this process you maximize utility.
You try to reduce the expenses and
you try to increase the return on,
uh,
what you try to achieve.
But let me also emphasize that Weber's
notion of instrumental rationality does
not say that the ends are
irrational, right? Uh,
and they were very much like
John Stuart mill is quiet or via,
that's the actually do have
preferences and there are some ants.
What we find more
valuable than other lans.
Instrumental rationality only means if
in order to achieve this end the is too
costly for us,
then we probably revealed wolf for
our second Beth and answer that there.
Then our first [inaudible], right? Uh,
so uh, there I would like
to date somebody. Um,
uh, I very much would
like to date that person,
but in order to have a successful date,
I have to take this person into a Forbes
five star restaurants bell that Bill
did dinner will cost me $200.
Now there is another person whom I
would not mind to date with, you know,
my second preference and that would go
over it a two star restaurant and would
cost me only 50 bucks and therefore,
you know, Ivl vate you know,
is this my preference for the first day
it is so strong that it is verse for me
to pay $200 or it's actually
not that much stronger.
My second preference is actually pretty
good and therefore I actually go for the
$50 at dinner. You see what I'm getting
at? So you are waiting rational,
the balls,
the ends and the means,
and you'll come to a conclusion again,
you know,
not all that far away from hops,
right?
And hops idea, right? Uh,
that we are, you know,
we do have these drives,
we have these appetites and we have
these fears and then we arrive at a veal.
This is instrumental rationality,
but he said people can act value,
rationality.
And if somebody adds value rationally,
I am not willing to call them
irrational there you rationality.
If somebody says,
this value is so important for me
that I don't care what is the price,
I will have to pay for it. Right? Um, uh,
let me give you a very simple example,
right?
You actually made think that human life
is particularly valuable right now.
Uh,
you or your partner may the expectation
get shy and then you will have to make a
decision where you give birth to this
child or do you have an abortion? Right?
And then it can come back
to value rationality. Right?
People can say that the life of an
onboard shine is so superior for me.
They'll do.
I know it is a very crazy stuff for me
to have a child or my partner to have a
child right now, I will do it, you know,
because I am active value rationally.
I know it is instrumental,
irrational, right? I may have
to create cool school, you know,
in order to earn an income or to
take care of the baby or something.
And I actually screwing my life.
But I don't mind.
I because I have such a strong value
commitment. You see what I'm getting at?
And you cannot say this is
irrational behavior, right?
This is rational behavior because people
has a commitment to an alternate value.
And these ultimate value occasionally
is so high that you are sacrificing your
economic interests.
And occasionally you sacrifice your life.
You are willing to die for noble causes,
right?
And you do it right. Um, uh, um, uh, uh,
rationally you vague but
you low that uveal die.
And if you know that you'd be
a die for these noble course,
one cannot say that you are
acting irrationally, uh,
uh,
factual orientation affect [inaudible]
mean that you are led by emotions.
You said it can be on the border line
because if it is simply an uncontrolled
reaction to a situation,
then it is irrational, right?
If you simply acting out of anger,
then you vote irrational, right?
Um, when you are drunk, uh,
in that party and you are saying something
to your partner and your relationship
is breaking up, you'll, you'll actually
wanted this relationship to go on.
Next morning you wake up and said, my
goodness gracious. What have I done?
Right? I was dumb. I was irrational.
I was led by emotions. I said,
thanks for that should not have said,
in this case a motion was
irrational. It was, um,
an uncontrolled reaction to a stimulation.
But otherwise to act out of love and
to make sacrifices for love is very
rational, right? We do this all the
time, right? Your parents do it,
you know,
they send you to,
to Yale and they paid $200,000
to get you a year degree.
Right. Bell very well over
there that probably they've,
you'll never get anything right that back
from you, right? They hope they view it.
Get some love back from you. What they
might or they might not write bots,
you know, they act out
of love. And you know,
some people may say you are crazy why
you invest so much to your children.
Maybe we'll put you in a home of hell
down right when you get old [inaudible]
right. All right. That
day. But the answer is,
but I love my child and I will upon
the best word that my child, right.
This is a very not irrational behavior.
They'll justify it. That'd be great.
These are traditional orientation
where you have talk of tradition,
right? Um, uh,
now some people actually still believe
in arranged marriages, right? Uh,
certainly if you are Islamic or
even if you are an Orthodox Jew,
you probably wanted to chip, choose your
partner through an arranged marriage,
right? You go to the rabbi and the
rabbi villa arranged a marriage for you.
You are,
you have to be pretty orthodox.
But there are some words that don't shoot.
So do manage Boston should do that.
Is it irrational, irrational? Actually,
Yvonne can say romantic love is not
all that bloody rational. You know,
the whole idea that you see somebody fall
in love and next day you propose that
seems to be pretty shitty
thing to do is not,
it is much better to go to
the rabbi who knows you,
who knows your prayer potential partner
and arrange the marriage what you
anyway,
the point is right tradition can
guide your action and that's again not
irrational.
It is only irrational.
It is completely on thinking.
That's,
I think that's very important to say
that not if it is self conscious,
you know what you do.
I do it because I am a Jew.
I am doing yet because I m f fun,
you know,
because I am at the born Christian
and that's what reborn Christians do,
right? If you follow this way, you
know, then you are acting rationally.
What not acting irrationally
to put it more now,
what is rationality now?
I think the key,
it's a very complex notion for me
and that you can have different
interpretation.
Now I will give you my interpretation.
I think what is importance,
right?
That the rationality means that
you sub substitute on thinking,
uh, acceptance of a situation
and uh, um, uh, uh, uh,
not thought out or uh,
spuntinos or the actions
do deliberate adaptation.
So when you are conscious about what
you are knowing a then you are actually
acting rationally ordered,
at least you are not acting irrationally.
He makes a distinction between
rational, which is, uh,
giving a great deal of
thought and non rational.
Where if actually there is still some
reflection of warring ground, uh,
Schlichter a major,
uh,
Weber's scholar who knows much
more about [inaudible] than I do.
Do I have read this book cover to
cover a couple of times? Um, uh,
I haven't tried order 60 volumes
soft faber cover to cover,
but have left quite a bit of it anyway.
I'm not sure if they'll have
read everything more than once.
This is his interpretation.
He said the question is means and aunts
instrumental rationality is the automat
rationality because you
consider most means and ends.
And he said,
value rationality is a lower level of
rationality because you do not consider a
really, um, uh, uh,
means annual longer that I'd ans dominate
and try the shrine and the factual
nationality are more marginal
types offered nationality.
Well, um, I would offer you
an alternative interpretation.
This is my reconstruct and sure enough
Yurigan harbor mass, we said Vale,
the VBA is emphasizing is what is the
level right off your reflectivity.
Do you really think
about what you are doing?
And also to what extent you can
communicate to ardors what you are doing.
And if you do it this way, you can
have reflexivity which is very high.
So you think very hard while you
are doing and you are over there,
but the motivation of your extra knees
and you can explain it to a grade due to
others if this is,
so I think this is really hard by mass
there your rationality is the highest
level of rationality,
right?
Because you can really
explain your values.
Very were instrumental rationality.
That is not much to say this is all in
the I am making more money this way.
Right?
And therefore the level of
communication is relatively low door.
You'll know very well
about you are doing anyway.
I just leave it for you don't
want to elaborate on this anymore,
but the bottom line is for Vba
rationality is he has something to do.
How conscious you are of what you are
doing and how conscious you are of the
consequences of your action.
You are irrational then you are,
you don't know what the
consequences of your actions. Now,
power and domination a ver makes a
fundamental difference between power in
German,
mocked and domination.
And this is a very important citation,
right?
Power is the probability
that an an activist and a
social relationship of you'll
be in a position to carry out.
He's only the oldest spy to resistance.
You can resist and never had their last.
The person who is in power can
force you to do what you want to do.
He said that these actually vet
rarely happens in social situations,
but typically defined social.
What's the situation?
Is relationships of domination.
That's about he costs, had a shaft.
Um, uh, um, uh, don't mean nation. Uh,
is the probability that a
command VOB obeyed, right?
Uh, the difference right
between, uh, um, uh, uh,
bow the nomination.
This is sort of my
little like lesion here.
Nomination is nothing else but
power and legitimacy, right?
The people who hold power
try to legitly mate,
what they do, you know, I was trying
to do this in the first 20 minutes.
Oh fuck. You know, you have these
questions, three sounds and if he got the,
I'm not difficult. They are exciting. You
know, they, I tried to legitimate myself.
This is sensible that you try to answer
discretion. You'll learn, you know,
you will understand society better.
You will understand yourself better if
you think about these questions, right?
I was trying to legitimate the process
letter then just acting out of,
or if by nine o'clock to
be or not be here, you've,
you'll get an F, right? And then you've,
you'll be in big trouble. Rajeev,
you'll not get your degree. No,
I did not want to legitimate.
I try to legitimate what we will
be doing this afternoon, right.
By the legitimacy saying this.
If it would be sensible for you to do,
you benefit from it, right?
I try to internalize, right?
But I want you to do between seven and
nine that you will be getting to believe.
This is good for me, that I'm
doing it. It is fun, right?
On the learning and the teaching myself,
this is my self development, right?
So I was trying to corn verb,
right? Power into
domination, um, and right.
And that is legitimacy.
A claim that what I'm doing then
I'm asking you a seven clock.
You know, not to have a,
um, uh, uh, a cocktail.
But to sit down in front of your computer
and to write a test is good for you,
right?
And if you internalize it and you're
beginning to think how wonderful you know
that I can delay the, these, a
cocktail for two hours, right?
Then I achieved, then I, you know, then it
was domination rather than power. Right?
Is that clear?
Now what is legitimacy?
This is a very tricky question.
Under the veil. I have my own view.
Many people will then
mentally disagree with to me.
Uh, he said, and that's very
important. Every January one,
form of domination implies a
minimum of voluntary compliance.
That is an interest in
obedience, right? Uh,
unless I could persuade you
that you will feel, they'll,
um, uh, I actually, uh,
uh, could, you know,
I could drop this course and not to
take this stats. This is too difficult.
I just dropped the course. I can live
with Saudi scores. Uh, uh, you, you,
you can have a kind of voluntary
compliance and most important,
and in us, you beginning to sing, well,
ivy learn something by doing this.
If I achieve that, then this,
this is really domination.
Uh, uh, now this is also extremely, uh,
Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
important argument, right? Uh,
that, um, uh, um, uh, every privilege,
globs of our people in position
of power are developing and myth,
uh, of their superiority.
We are devil thing emit,
uh, that this is, uh, uh,
useful for you to obey.
So the essence right of legitimacy,
that it has a certain,
expect you to believe in the reasons,
but those in position of power
try to justify their power.
But also an understanding that this is
a myth because this is a light comes to
very close to nature.
This is the niche is sticking
his head out here. All right?
Uh, it is a methodology.
It's not really true, right?
You just internalize your own a
submission to the authority, right?
But you,
but the tendency in histories
that you will internalize it.
So this is very different
from what we normally say,
legitimacy because by legitimacy in
contemporary political discourse reefers
well, uh, uh,
[inaudible] is not legitimate
because he was faking the elections.
If elections are fair, um, and three,
then the person who is elected is
a legitimate glue ruler. No, no,
that's not Weber's view.
It's not a universe of uh,
uh,
suffrage and free and fair elections.
What makes the ruler legitimate but maze
the ruler legitimate that the ruler is
capable to develop metallurgies to
justified that you better obey the orders,
what is given to you because you have
some self interest to do so and you have
some level of belief that it is actually
not bad for you to do what the ruler
wants you to do.
Right now,
there are different types of domination
and authority and this is bad.
He clashes right with my,
as you as we have seen Reich's Mark's
developed his diaper ology of societies
from economic systems,
economy drives history.
Uh, um, vapor is a new chair and hops,
yen or Nichier, right? But
drives history is power,
struggle for power and the nature of our,
how power is constructed and how our
power is a sublimated right into a
domination to put it in
the Friday and way. Uh,
that is how she, you should
understand how societies operate.
So it is not more so production.
What describes the evolution of his 30,
but types of domination,
which describes the evolution of history
and that are really three types of,
uh, uh, uh,
what he calls legitimate
authorities that are three days,
how rulers in history
legitimated their rules.
It can be legal, rational, uh,
easily. You can say liberal,
uh,
traditional and charismatic and
Vivio spend the time on this.
Each one of them are just very
briefly tell you what, uh,
these different authorities are legal or
National Authority is a system in which
that is a belief in the
legality of enacting the rules.
Um,
uh,
and the doors who are
actually issuing the commands,
they themselves are bound by those rules.
By this is the rule of law.
That's why he caused legal,
rational authority.
It is rule of law administered
in a bureaucratic manner.
You do not have a personal master.
You do not obey a person.
You obey the rules of
the game, right? And the,
and these rules of the game I prescribed,
you know,
in advance because before you act,
it is sad and you followed these,
that is legal, rational authority.
This is not identical
with the avid democracy.
If can be democratic or
it can the authoritarian,
it can be actually a
constitutional monarchy rather
constitutional monarch pass
laws by a separate legislature,
which was or was not democratically
elected, but everybody knew who the,
who the rules of the game are. Right?
In our constitutional monarchy,
18th century,
early 19th century England,
no democratically elected parliament.
Right?
But the laws were there and the monarch
followed the law or laws that was legal,
rational authority. Uh, uh,
then you have traditional authority,
traditional authority,
he said rests on the established
beliefs on the sanctity of in memorial
traditions and the legitimacy of those
exercising the authority under them.
In some ways, you know, when
you are obeying, you are father,
you are acting under
traditional authority.
The authority,
what your father has is ascribe
to your father by tradition,
right?
The know that this is something,
but fathers do have a
legitimate right to say, right?
Uh, that in fact, you know,
fathers do have a legitimate right to
say that by midnight you have to be at
home, right? They kind of are not
very happy about this. You know,
when you were 16, you started to
the vote against this, but you know,
you accepted this is normally what
you know, fathers or mothers to say,
you know, and you know, you
also said, well, uh, um,
are you did something and therefore for
this weekend you cannot go out. Right.
And they are acting out of
traditional authority or authority,
which ascribed to them by tradition.
Um,
uh, and finally, that is charismatic
authority. This is a very complex issue.
We will talk about this a great deal.
Charismatic Authority refers to the
fact when a leader is trying to,
um, uh, legitimate,
it's right to issue commands that he's
has some extra ordinary character that
he's some single, like a,
you know, an extra ordinary,
unusual person,
but is also very important to see,
uh,
that
the are often seen as super natural or
events superhuman having exceptional
qualities. Uh, but what is
also very important to see,
uh,
that charismatic authority in Labor is
not really the characteristics of the
individual.
This is what we attribute to the
individuals to have these extra ordinary
characteristics.
In the most recent US history
during the electoral, uh,
uh, during the presidential
campaign, uh, Barack Obama of it,
he's a charming personality,
which is extra ordinary
skills of delivering speeches,
was capable to create a,
um,
a kind of charismatic aura around himself,
right?
People got excited, you know, almost
like around the rock star, right?
They, and his whole, uh,
arguments for trying to
legitimate himself was very much,
uh, uh, passed in
charismatic terms, right?
A whole you can believe in.
Right?
This is a very typical charismatic appeal.
You have to believe in me because I'm
offering you hope in a hopeless situation,
right?
That's what creates charismatic authority.
How much charismatic authority
President Obama's still has.
This is another question,
right?
What you may want to discuss
in the discussion section
is also a problem better.
You know, uh, uh, uh,
candidate Obama was really a
charismatic leader, a vapor,
basically define charismatic leaders as
the great leaders create the makers of
create world religions.
Jesus Christ was a charismatic leader.
So in some ways to say modern politicians,
they are charismatic.
It's a bit slippery.
But I think the emphasis on hope and,
uh,
the call, you'll believe me because
I, they'll be able to deliver. Yes,
we can. You know, I remember when
I first heard him saying that,
I said, yeah, that's exactly
the charismatic at Dia, right?
It's not quite reason.
Doubt, right? It is.
And it moved me when when he,
when Barack Obama came out and he said,
you think nothing can be done,
but yes,
we can hope you can believe in.
Right.
This is very much a charismatic appeal.
That's what got is medical
product is all about.